[Music]
[Applause]
Dr Mark addicts has been on this program
many times Harvard Medical School grad
orthopedic surgeon and former offensive
lineman in the NFL great to talk to you
again doc
um Brock Purdy seeing another or getting
another opinion what if it's torn what
can other that other opinion be
well I mean I think every athlete won
they want more than one person to tell
them that the path that the first doctor
uh told them to take is the correct path
and then secondly everybody kind of
wants to say oh maybe it's just partial
you know they're hoping that the next
Doctor will tell them they don't need
surgery I mean looking at the hit
looking at his absolute inability to
throw the ball it looks to me like uh he
needs surgery he needs Tommy John
surgery and You Know It generally is a
year you know I mean Stephen Strasberg
came back in a year in in in baseball we
had Jake the loam came back in just over
a year actually he was hurting week
three and then came back the following
season had probably his best year after
he had Tommy John so it's not that I
don't think he'll be able to come back
and play well it's just that it may
completely
make next season not an option I said
that yesterday Doc and then I saw the
update it's like oh he could be back
right before for the start of training
camp and I'm thinking this isn't the
Tommy John surgery that I know and then
I'm wondering is is the Tommy John
surgery is it different for a
quarterback than it would be for a
pitcher
what's odd is you would think throwing a
heavier ball that you'd have more Tommy
John surgeries with football
quarterbacks but you know one there are
a lot fewer football quarterbacks than
there are pitchers but
um no they're more they're more UCL
injuries in in baseball throwers than
there are in football throwers it really
is a more rare injury now can you come
back faster you know I don't think
you're throwing you know 50 yard bombs
60-yard bombs uh with an elbow six
months after their surgery you know I
mean it it takes about three months to
heal and you know I mean every now and
then you'll see a baseball player come
back in nine months and they're like oh
my gosh can you believe it this guy came
back I mean that's just you know
knocking it out of the park to come back
after Tommy John in nine months and I do
think that that's possible six months
would make him would make him pretty
miraculous and uh you know I'm
unfamiliar with someone being able to
play quite that soon yeah I was there
with you I haven't had that surgery but
you know understanding what pictures go
through and then I wondered you know the
demand that's going to be on that elbow
moving forward you know it's a it's a
violent motion with a pitcher not
necessarily with a football player but
if you gave him a nine month window even
then would he be able to play uh and
that of course will open up this
speculation that maybe Tom Brady is uh
ready to come in let me ask you about a
couple of weeks with uh Patrick Mahomes
resting that ankle will mean what for
the Super Bowl
well I mean it's pretty miraculous you
know playing on one foot uh the the day
he heard it and then last week I mean
last week he wasn't anywhere near normal
maybe 70
66. you know I think he's gonna be
closer to 85. I I still think he's gonna
be a little bit gimpy I still think uh
his Mobility is going to be somewhat
affected I actually think it's kind of
like the golfer you know who's uh who's
got a little bit of an ailment and so
they swing at 80 percent uh sometimes it
helps their game you know if is Patrick
not relying on his Mobility uh is it is
it forcing him to read defenses even
more quickly I mean we already know he
can throw it and throw it accurately and
throw it deep but you know I don't know
I I almost felt uh as he threw in five
yards on one foot last week that maybe
he was even better in some ways
obviously the mobility wasn't but he did
run for a first now at the end so you
know I think he'll be 85 but it may
actually make him a better quarterback
you have the tuatanga violoa situation
uh I don't know how much you've
addressed concussions in your line of
work but he's still in concussion
protocol and this is five weeks Mark
um you know can you are you more
susceptible to more concussions the more
you have
that we've done studies but it it
certainly does appear that way I mean
anecdotally I think that that when
someone's had a concussion it it seems
to me that they they get concussions
more readily and so that when you're
when you're talking about someone being
in concussion protocol that just means
that he still has symptoms probably as
he tries to work out you know because
that's the first thing to do is they put
them through a cardiovascular workout
and and so he he must you know have
symptoms when he's trying to work out
probably not at rest but probably when
he's trying to work out and until he's
completely asymptomatic you know they
can't they can't say that he's cleared
from protocol and and yes it's worrisome
I mean it's worrisome if someone's
having repeated head injuries I mean
certainly if my son was having repeated
head injuries I'd tell him to to quit
playing
yeah that's what Chris Collinsworth said
doc that at some point you know he's
young and he's got the rest of his life
and might be the rest of his life
without football
it might be it might be you know I mean
I love watching him play and I I thought
he was a real great story this year uh
coming out of the gates it looked like
Miami was going to be but you know in
contention for the AFC title but
um yeah so I mean I certainly want him
healthy and that's what's most important
but uh I'd miss watching them Kyler
Murray's uh injury uh yeah ACL meniscus
uh that's going to take a little bit
longer than people probably expect
yeah straightforward ACL you can you can
see guys come back pretty pretty
reliably between six and nine months and
then when you throw a meniscus in there
it goes more to nine to twelve
um so you know we'll just have to see
see how he does some some people can
still you know get back in seven eight
months after after an ACL with a
meniscus I mean he's a pretty young guy
and he's not a very big guy I mean
certainly I wonder though he's such a
water bug and he he changes Direction so
quickly that uh you know you wonder if
this is gonna affect his game to some
degree oh yeah I I you know that because
he relies on his legs as much if not
more than anybody else in the NFL that's
where I'd have some trepidation there uh
for sure how many concussion did you
even count concussions when you played
in the NFL
no I mean I honestly I didn't I I I mean
I had a number that that you know I told
the trainers about and you know maybe
came out of a practice
um but most most most concussions were
were unreported when I played I mean you
you and honestly they haven't during
interceptions because the defensive
lineman was there it was their time to
get back at us offensive line when they
were trapping them and and you know
blindsiding them down the field and so
they they would get back at us and
that's where a number of my concussions
occurred and uh are you watching a sport
that you're unfamiliar with the way it
was played when you played and and the
way it's played now well I mean what's
interesting is there was a code and the
code was you you didn't want to
intentionally injure somebody and and so
the last thing you would do is go at
somebody's knees but but you know I mean
just like boxing or MMA you know a a
good clean shot to the to the head was
was legal and and if you you know and if
somebody got a concussion to me we just
we just said you got your bell wrong you
listen yeah you know it was all
everything was downplayed and then you
know it was it was ignorance all around
I mean I don't blame anybody for it but
um I I mean I it is better and and the
thing is is we love the without great
quarterback the NFL is not much fun to
watch right and so I'm okay with it I
know I was the defensive lineman I would
hate it but but uh as a fan I'm I'm okay
with it great to talk to you again doc I
hope you're doing well and thanks for
joining us
thanks for having me on Jeff have a
great day Dr Mark addicts uh he's uh
Harvard Medical School grad and played
in the NFL he was uh on the 1991 Super
Bowl champion uh Washington team and
also spent nine years with DirecTV the
fantasy Zone medical expert and that's
why when they say six months for Brock
Purdy
I gotta believe it's at least nine
months